hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's the time of year when annualised
videogames throw down their latest
markers the WWE video game lineage is no
different and has been a yearly outing
for almost 18 years now back in the old
school days the story mode from WWF
Smackdown to know your role was the
greatest thing I ever played and over
the years some of the games have been
absolutely brilliant whereas others have
not been so fantastic if you are like me
and a bit skeptical of buying the same
game every year then here's 7 new things
improvements and updates in WWE 2k 18
that distance itself from last year's
version and by the way try to spot as
many hidden wrestling moves in the
voiceover as you can like you'd expect a
spot based annual video game is all
about the updated roster 2k 18 has a
record-breaking 174 unique playable
characters with 203 playable characters
in total if you include their
alternative versions this will grow
again with DLC characters but for a base
game this is a rich pedigree of
superstars this year also sees the
women's revolution continue with 30
playable women on disc yet another
record newcomers to the roster include
sanity Payton royce norway jose ember
moon and my personal favorite Bobby
Roode you may see a man rotating on a
cake stand but what I see is truly
glorious
the improved lighting and shaders in the
game takes the visuals to a new level
you could say it's the coup de Gras
bringing the visual one step closer to
reality each of the entrances now pop
and allow every contour of a character's
model to be clearly defined I'm usually
not one to marvel over a few shadows on
a man's torso but it is a welcome
addition the camera angles used on a
typical WWE show are present here too
with the hardcamp switching to handheld
close-ups almost identical to those on
Raw for a WWE game to truly feel like
the real thing we need more than big
sweaty men and a few Pyro's we need the
whole experience to sound right and as
up-to-date as possible
that's where the new announce team for
2k 18 comes in Michael Cole returns with
Corey graves and Byron Saxton alongside
him this means Jerry the King Lawler and
the much hated JBL have been given the
elbow drop with so much on the line here
in this ladder match he has no choice
but to find a way to overcome this
attack guys by the looks of things I
don't think he expected his opponent to
be as motivated as he clearly is here
tonight sadly I'm still a bit
shell-shocked that there is no room for
Maranello but that will hopefully be
rectified next time around whilst we are
speaking about the game sound then I
will also add that the crowd reactions
chants and signs have been updated for
2k 18 so hopefully it will be switching
music to our ears if you've ever watched
the battle royal or some of the hectic
moments in a Royal Rumble then you
witnessed the sheer number of people in
the ring at once in 2k 17 we could just
about have 6 people doing the graphs
without a loss in quality well 2k 18
have given us a twist of fate and now
supports 8 wrestlers in the ring at the
same time expect absolute bedlam in
matches and it may take a little
attitude adjustment to get used to too
quick for him there there he goes
crashing to the floor in ring changes
are a little more subtle but the new
carry mechanic is a game changer or a
showstopper if you prefer instead of
awkwardly dragging an opponent or trying
to Irish whip them into the right
position the carry system allows your
superstar to maneuver one another in
four positions shoulder cradle fireman's
lift and the power
so for example if you want to go up to
your opponent on the ropes simply pick
them up and go for it but keep in mind
the smaller wrestlers won't be able to
lift the likes of the Big Show and all
wrestlers will feel the fatigue when
carrying others around the ring it's
somewhat of a muscle buster
the carrying mecanic can also be
reversed to so we won't be completely
helpless in this scenario but if you're
counting about now you haven't been
paying attention he has more resolved
than just about anybody on the roster
one of the biggest draws to the 2k
franchise is the comprehensive creation
suite I even used it last year to create
Jeff Hardy before he resigned with the
WWE
well 2k 18 have doubled down on
customization the smallest detail has
undergone an evolution even the menu
policies can be changed with hand
positions altered and expressions
drastically improved this isn't simply
your character design either referee
attire can be selected for each match
and those matches can be fully
customized to highlights from each of
your bouts can be effortlessly made into
a show reels by your characters entrance
making 2k 18 the most immersive yet
simply stunning stunning stunning
definite that one didn't work okay I can
do better and finally something to
bookend this list career modes let's be
honest for a moment the career modes in
previous WWE titles have been a bit poor
never hit a rock bottom but never really
achieving the million-dollar dream they
set out to be that's where the road to
glory and the new and improved my career
modes will hopefully turn our cross base
upside down Road to Glory utilizes
online play to build your character up
to the big leagues you'll compete
against other users from all around the
world to level up from a prospect to a
hall-of-famer and you'll also be
attempting to qualify for participation
in WWE pay-per-views which run parallel
to the real-life events you will unlock
loot boxes on your way which if you're
as lucky as this person will include a
pair of the rocks trunks let's hope
they're washed or there could be trouble
in paradise if you're not really one for
online play because usually the opponent
does the exact same move repeatedly then
rest assure my career mode will be
around story lines with all new
cutscenes and scenarios never seen
before and that's not enough then
universe mode returns with new rivalries
and even more storylines to discover so
there we have seven new things coming to
WWE 2k 18 there are so many more little
things coming - such as backstage free
roaming brand new oMG moves oh and the
money shot for many players the brand
split is here to 2k 18 releases on the
ps4 and the Xbox one on October the 17th
are you tempted by 2k 18 or will you be
giving this one a Miss did you purchase
lucky as game what did you think
is it really losing its X Factor or
would you give it a five star rating
right it's time for my curtain call I'm
Adam from PlayStation granade it's been
a pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]
still here then you must be a WWE fan
how many wrestling moves did you hear
during the voiceover I challenge you to
find all 24 if you are busy now then
come back in your spare time or when
Irish Chris that can if you haven't
found them all then go to sleep for a
while and try again tomorrow
good luck I'll see you later